okay to push psychobabble here the main
man Donald Trump there's a mission in
the colonial tap house so if we're gonna
check it out hmm in some pizza pretty
good easy I don't think she wants to
leave just yet hey this is between me
and my wife why don't you mind your own
damn business for once oh why do you
always have to exceed pour me another
drink damn it Darcy I just want you to
come home I'll be home can't believe you
do this to me cook and what to you Paul
you keep away from my wife goddamn it
you better get out at me before you do
something stupid so the pitch go on get
out of here i'll be at home Darcy taking
care of our son hmm step
sorry I had to see that these are
usually a lot quieter around perfect
place to drink if you're buying what was
that argument uh sure you see he's not
up you there uh why don't you ask
yourself you sure free boo anyway I got
a fog around ordering not interested all
right then okay char customer let me ask
you sure ask away just with everything
that's happened with you family the
whole hell of a lot to process wanted to
make sure you holdin up yeah I'm all
right enough with me a long damn thank
goodness I found diamond of course when
I took up their back the massacre of the
cpg was still pretty fresh in people's
minds at that point plenty of people
assumed I was just a saboteur but at the
time broken mask this was long before I
but apparently guess he didn't like the
food Deitrick my security finally put
enough jun ji mal funk it was the first
time people realized since that stop
looking like me uh-huh sidering what
these folks went through why'd they let
you win cuz I'd rescue demands don't gal
of about fifteen the young miss Roberts
decide turns out the guy was part of a
gang I took her home and the mayor
doesn't mean taking up in the city was
was it hard settling in they sure didn't
I started off doing the job I guess
folks never forgotten wife runs off with
a new an upset father after a while the
jobs got so back right hell I was so
happy to do it it was I never stopped
being Nicklaus in but it was uh huh
about then the thing took me along a
long story okay that's weird anyway the
quest get started and network Valentine
on good people you know what I mean um
next time I see that dude that just got
like beat up in town so um let me see
where I could find him let him at the
bar yeah hey you there I am I have a
question for you I'm listenin go ahead
um you were in the taphouse book on her
get your ass kicked you got your ass
kicked by your wife lover yeah guys
sleeping with my wife hmm sounds like a
tweed another half I'm not gonna just uh
huh I'm going to go back and talk to UM
bread you saw you won't take me
seriously otherwise don't want to happen
I'll help okay okay good
I'll do it a lot actually work better if
I talk to cook by myself you're probably
right I am so angry equipment here we
got diamond city blows he'll get that I
sell make sure cook good don't kill him
if you don't have to but otherwise I
don't care what let's do this baby let's
[ __ ] him out on his wife I wanted so
much more from my life in this choice
our hottest [ __ ] my husband dragged you
into any of his nonsense hey
don't be late yeah yeah I'll be there I
just have to close up hello [ __ ] hmm
are you lost [ __ ] ass huh you're
Henry cook right that's right this is my
place is salia why they're some kind
turenne you're going to leave dark now
wait just a goddamn minute uh-huh turn
we can do this though I've left tougher
than you bleeding in the dirt you'd
better turn my huh Tran last chance take
it easy we can talk this through this
whole thing with Darcy and me bad idea
not like I planned look tell Paul it no
okay okay like I have an idea something
I've been hmm this had better be here's
the deal I have some other right one of
them is helping Nelson Lattimer spent
his dad's money to make himself guess it
to the point I'm getting to it sure me
and Nelson are supposed to be meeting
some gentlemen from good neighbor to
exchange my plan is simple uh-huh Huck
I'm in now you're talking I promise
wait the focus is what the [ __ ]
okay and a quick save this match you're
heading outside the wall I want to stock
up at Commonwealth weapon where are you
pop I'm but alright yeah there he is yes
hope he's got his pants up
Cook has a plan to make us both rich
ambush a ken do you think it's a good
idea the meat is right down ah cook
won't be bothering Darcy anymore good I
knew you could handle him so what
happens he give you any trouble nah
nothing I couldn't okay I don't sure
anyway good luck Thanks
tire say hey how and I have a child I
regret a lot of things but not my little
Pete okay that's a little [ __ ] up but
ok yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah let's go busy excuse me what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I all shoot you in the
[ __ ] face mess I'm very aware this
thing is at oh yes yes probably nothing
distress call came its ruins ok
you know [ __ ] up that deal
Oh
[ __ ] okay I'll hold on yeah my bearings
ik you come from across the drawers yes
sir we're too [ __ ] right things
faster Shay's it's a [ __ ] slow
okay where's the deal going down it's an
hour I now yes they all starting to
think he doesn't need me
are the two points ambush the chem deal
here we are the meat it's just a head
there's always for morale skis goons
Trish who's in charge and then three
other guys to unload the boat and wave
their guns around you should be able to
work the way around these buildings to
get a good angle
ah I said limbs are all [ __ ] out don't
move ah you don't have to kill me Oh doc
I swear
give me a reason not I don't need a
better reason than to shut her up Odell
marasca was gonna go on where do you
think these kids come from but don't
ever tell me what you know okay I'm
trusting you right the lab is in the old
for Lee Fishman what's your about all
the place is overrun with feral ghouls
which are her I assume that Neil assume
the real security is a system of trip
wires that have to be triggered in exact
you never even know but now I do yeah
laced so I have you
and you promise to not tell them her up
yeah yeah of course are you talked to a
freilich password is Applejack there
night I hope you can live with yes so
that's that I told you it was no problem
the money should still be on Nelson's
body and then there's these chems which
you'll need to sell but that's your
problem now I'm leaving town for good
you in there much cat God God ok game
access to the chem 10 where's that wait
that's right [ __ ] out there if I get
[ __ ] i divided the spoils perfectly
now I have to get what the why mmm
chocolate on my lips chocolate on my
lips [ __ ] gold all over the place
okay I [ __ ] is that noise she says she's
gone crazy
Claire that [ __ ] out no it still [ __ ]
out up there okay okay I clean this up
huh
it is really cool the once you clear
someone out it like stays quiet out
thank God okay well it's cool is that
[ __ ] great it's gonna be so annoying
holy [ __ ]
I had to put on my [ __ ] hazmat suit
where is that
can't be disarmed
okay guy we got it how [ __ ] shooting
shet can't [ __ ] sec here
okay okay
what's gonna happen the [ __ ] now that
[ __ ] happen okay I did it I did it
[ __ ] here
is that I got stash house are like no
safe where there's not like a [ __ ] ton
of money Jesus sculpt the gas dryer and
there if i'll get shad here